[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: My team asked
me to research VMs and see
how they compare to other
cloud-native approaches
like microservices,
containers, serverless,
and to be honest with you, I
am not excited about it at all,
so I brought in someone who is.
Brian, resident VM expert.
BRIAN DORSEY: Hello, hello!
I'm super happy to
be here because I
am really excited about VMs.
CARTER MORGAN: How?
See, this is why I
wanted to bring you here.
I don't understand.
How can you be so excited
about VMs already?
BRIAN DORSEY: How can you not?
It is like the best
of both worlds.
You know, you've got a
stable, reliable system
you can run anything on,
and you're in the Cloud,
close to all of the
new features and you
get new automation tooling.
CARTER MORGAN: See, that's what
I'm kind of skeptical about.
When I think about modern
systems or anything like that,
I'm not sure that a VM
can provide me with those.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
Well, let's be kind
of specific there.
What do you mean
by a modern system?
CARTER MORGAN: When I think
about a modern system I think
about things like modularity,
I think about scalability
and reliability.
I want automation.
I don't want to have to
do everything manually.
I even think about
portability and being
able to move my workflows
whatever they need to go.
So I want things to
just kind of work too,
and I don't want to have
to do everything myself.
BRIAN DORSEY: Got it.
CARTER MORGAN: Is that
something I can get with a VM?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
great, because I actually
think we can get most of that.
And I kind of wonder why not?
So let's go one level deeper
and then we'll come back out.
So in your mind, what is a VM?
CARTER MORGAN: Oh.
You're putting me
on the spot, Brian.
OK.
A VM is-- it's a computer,
but it's a virtualization.
It's a slice of a computer.
And so what it lets you do is it
lets you run multiple operating
systems on one machine.
So it looks like you have
multiple machines running
on one physical machine.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yep.
Absolutely.
And in the Cloud, kind of not.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh.
What?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, so
here's why I say not.
So the abstractions
are all there, right?
So you've got memory,
CPU, disk, networking.
And instead of from one
computer, in the Cloud,
that's coming from all of the
computers in a data center.
So the CPU is coming
from a lot of machines.
The networking is from
the whole data center.
And so I like to think
about it as instead
of a slice of a computer, it's
a slice of the data center.
CARTER MORGAN: Instead
of a slice of a computer,
it's a slice of a data center.
That sounds interesting,
impressive, even,
but also abstract.
So do you have
some examples of--
maybe you can get from a Cloud
VM that you can't get from a VM
on one machine?
BRIAN DORSEY: So my
turn to be specific.
Yeah, so I think one
example is like bin packing.
So you talk about these VMs,
and they're different shapes.
So you have one that
needs a lot of CPU,
another needs a lot of memory.
Maybe you've got a bunch
of them need a lot of CPU,
and they don't fit so
well in the same box
without kind of orphaning
some of the memory or CPU.
And if you're running those
in a whole data center,
you know, or you can
basically just leave
it to Google to
solve that problem,
you can just have whatever
shape machine you want,
and we'll figure
out where to put it.
And basically, that lets
you customize your machines
to exactly what you need.
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
that's very interesting,
because that's a hard problem.
And so if you can
just let Google
handle where your
workloads are going to go,
that's a good benefit.
If that's the only
benefit of Cloud VMs,
though, I'm not sure I'm sold
on them over other approaches.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
CARTER MORGAN: Is there
anything else we got?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
There's a ton of stuff we
could talk about in terms
of automation and other things.
But I think another
really concrete kind
of specific example is disks,
and it's kind of my favorite
there.
Because you think
of a physical disk,
and you read and write
blocks from it, right?
It's a block device.
In the data center
level, those blocks
could be on hundreds
or thousands
of different machines.
And so all of them
are working together
to give you more
reliability and make
things smoother, more
predictable in terms
of performance.
So what you get out
of it is something
that looks a lot like a SAN.
You can take backups of
disks that are running, even.
Or you can-- if
you run out space,
like I think almost
all of us have,
you can just make
the disk bigger.
So things like that.
CARTER MORGAN: That's
impressive, especially
like you're saying, if you're
going to run and just scale
up, scale down, or resize.
OK, then another very
targeted question.
It's going to sound like
a dig, I don't mean it to.
Google's putting a lot
of effort and resources
in the Google containers end.
And so is Google even
still investing in VMs?
BRIAN DORSEY: I
mean, absolutely.
Where do you think
these containers run?
Like, so every
Kubernetes cluster
is running on top of a
whole bunch of VMs, right?
And so everything
you learn about VMs
applies to those clusters
that you're running.
And also another example is
our managed databases, so Cloud
SQL.
So if you're running Postgres
or MySQL on Cloud SQL,
that's running on VMs.
And there's a bunch
of other examples too.
CARTER MORGAN: I can't get
away from VMs even if I tried,
it sounds like.
BRIAN DORSEY: Nope.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
The way you're saying
that is making me
think that maybe,
maybe I need to rethink
my idea that VMs are just old,
dusty pieces of technology.
So I want to be
clear, definitively,
are you saying that VMs have a
place in a cloud-native future?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
So I want to kind of
take old and dusty,
and turn that into mature
and reliable, right?
And then the future
part, so all these things
are built on top
of it, and we're
building new things over time.
So we've got tools
for scaling clusters
of machines up and down.
That's using Kubernetes,
but you can use it directly.
And we keep investing and doing
more and more things there,
so absolutely part of
the future as well.
CARTER MORGAN: So, OK.
And then what about if I
wanted to switch to them?
You know, I'm pretty
familiar with Kubernetes.
It's fairly easy to get started.
What about with a VM?
Is it going to take me years
to get started on these?
BRIAN DORSEY: No, I mean
it's just a computer.
So basically, anything that's
already running on a computer
somewhere, even
if you don't have
the team who built it nearby,
you can run that on a VM.
And in turn, you can
run on a Cloud VM
and get a bunch of the
Cloud benefits as well.
CARTER MORGAN: All right,
I must admit that you've
swayed me a little bit.
I'm still skeptical, but what
you said made a lot of sense.
I still have a lot of questions.
I want to know about
keeping costs down.
how do I update VMs?
I have this idea in my
head that they're really
slow to start and stop.
Staple data, I'm curious
about that, you know?
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome,
how much time do you have?
CARTER MORGAN: All
right, you know what?
Let's have this
convo another day,
and maybe, just
maybe, we can agree
that VMs do matter in
a cloud-native future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]